moi j'ai commencé la musique à 6 ans par
hasard je suis arrivé dans une maison il
y avait un piano à queue et donc je me
suis naturellement sur ce piano et j'ai
adoré la musique
alors mes parents ont voulu m'inscrire
piano il est plus plat c'est donc qu'ils
sont les allées on est dans les années
80 tu vas faire des facs dont j'allais
27 ou 28 ans on m'a proposé de faire une
tournée avec patricia kaas là je devais
apprendre la clarinette très rapidement
j'avais quinze jours par l'internet
c'est assez proche du sa xv et doigté
commun et à son souper commune aussi
mais voilà quinze jours c'était vraiment
rapide donc j'ai décidé d'apprendre et
clarinette avec l'auto hypnose sur elle
à l'audition et on m'a demandé de faire
un second
donc moi j'avais prolongé compris comme
ça donc voilà il y pousse à toujours
fait un peu partie ma vie
[Musique]
j'ai fait pas mal de tourner il faudrait
cinq à dix pôles d'abord tout ça et puis
avait un moment où je me suis dit j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait un peu le tour
j'ai besoin d'être de faire ma musique
d'une façon plus personnelle puis je me
sentais un peu plus utile donc comment
je vais pouvoir allier la musique avec
quelque chose de n'être plus un peu plus
thérapeutique est donc là j'ai eu l'idée
des concerts physiquement aussi donc ça
c'était en 2015
[Musique]
c'est voulu comme un voyage initiatique
donc le public comme lors d'une
cérémonie chamanique le public pose une
intention j'ai mal au dos je veux que ça
s'apaise j'étais problème avec les
personnes ce que ça s'arrange genre de
truc est en fait cette intention mais
bien souvent quand on a un objectif des
fois on a du mal à réaliser parce qu'il
ya des choses en nous qui nous bloque
les peurs inconscientes plein de trucs
comme ça
bon bah là avec ce concert sous hypnose
le projet c'est que la personne puisse
voir les causes de ce qui fonctionne pas
pourquoi depuis quand quelle autre
ressource est là reste que son objectif
c'est vraiment un objectif qu'important
pour r
il ya la musique à peu près tout le long
et effectivement il ya des moments où la
musique est beaucoup moins forte et moi
je vais faire vite moscou dessus donc je
vais me dit qu'elle est confiante au
monde son jeu s'il est là et ensuite
s'il ya les morceaux qui correspond à ce
que j'ai dit qu'ils vont emmener les
personnes dans leurs émotions et dans
l'eure à l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes dans le
reee close
une hausse que j'utilise ces minots
ericksonienne donc c'est une dose qui
est tous les gens crédules et un an
l'hôpital et les conflits qui marche sur
tout le monde et si on allait encore
plus loin dans l'expérience alors vous
reprenez le chemin et vous continuez à
avancer un pas un mois un an le temps
défile de plus en plus vers le futur et
vous avancez de plus en plus loin 10 ans
20 ans 30 ans et s'il était possible de
rencontrer la version de vous même
la plus sage n'a plus réalisé la plus
aboutie la version de vous même au
dernier jour de votre vie qui aurait
tenté tant de choses à vous transmettre
[Musique]